alors cette cette idée de donner
confiance mais c'est aussi cette
présence de laine on la retrouve dans
les paroles des enfants des enfants ils
reprennent les paroles des adultes et on
le voit dans le reportage de maryse
burgot ian moines dans les écoles de
mitrovica deux heures de cours par jour
c'est peu mais c'est un début et c'est
aussi une revanche
pendant des années ces petits albanais
ont étudié dans des écoles clandestines
leurs professeurs refusait alors
d'appliquer les programmes de belgrade
pour pouvoir renseigner dans leur propre
langue
ils furent obligés de quitter le système
éducatif légal alors aujourd'hui
ne comptez pas sur ces écoliers pour
accepter des petits serbe sur les mêmes
bancs donc jamais connu trop de crimes
et nous là l'autre alors nous on ne veut
pas parler comme un modem n'a de toute
façon ils veulent tous nous tuer
tout peut arriver elle vient à l'école
en zone albanais remet elle vit dans la
partie serbe de la ville guilhem est
donc une élève qu'il faut protéger les
soldats de la kfor l'escort matin et
soir elle grandira donc avec ses
souvenirs de retour d'école amblainville
difficile pour elle pour l'instant de
voir les serbes autrement qu'en mai
jurés et de l'autre côté la défiance est
la même dans le village de plémy tina la
kfor a construit une école albanais en
face de celle des serbes
il était impossible de faire cohabiter
les uns et les autres entre les mêmes
murs mais l'idée était au moins de les
rapprocher
c'est finalement un échec les
professeurs se débrouillant pour que les
récréations ne tombe jamais en même
temps ça c'est à cause de cette guerre
les albanais se sont tous des
terroristes qui brûlent les maisons des
serbes les programmes scolaires ne sont
de toute façon pas les mêmes les
professeurs serbe ayant par exemple une
vision de l'histoire
à l'opposé de celle des albanais l'école
multi ethnique au kosovo est aujourd'hui
un rêve
figées dans les gestes doux victoire
égouts revanche des uns et des autres